herzlich willkommen ja heute widmen wir
uns ganz dem spieltrieb des menschen und
gehen gleichzeitig einem mega phänomen
unserer zeit auf dem grund wir tauchen
ein in die welt der videospiele in die
welt der games
angefangen hat alles ganz einfach
in den 70er jahren dann wurden die games
immer komplexer die rechner schneller
die grafik realistischer immer mehr
menschen tauchen ein in fiktive
spielwelten kämpfen fahren rennen lösen
rätsel weltweit gaming heute mehr als
2,3 milliarden menschen also jeder
dritte es werden sogar sogenannte e
sport wettkämpfe in stadien ausgetragen
games sind zum großen geschäft geworden
die game industrie ist die am stärksten
wachsende branche der welt in den
letzten 20 jahren hat sich der umsatz
der game industrie vervierfacht auf
knapp 140 milliarden us dollar einzelne
games haben ein entwicklungsbudget von
bis zu 600 millionen dollar mehr als
jeder hollywood film ja ganz schön
beeindruckend wenn sie mich fragen aber
was fasziniert denn so viele menschen an
videospielen und sind sie wirklich wie
experten meinen die kunstwerke der
zukunft diese fragen diskutieren ich
heute mit meinen gästen philomena schwab
ist game designerin und entwirft ganze
game welten hier in zürich zählt
weltweit zu den wichtigsten personen
unter 30 jahren im technologiebereich
und dominik erhard ist ebenfalls noch
nicht 30 und beschäftigt sich als
philosoph mit der frage warum der mensch
denn eigentlich nur da ganz mensch ist
wo er spielt herzlich willkommen ihnen
beim sie beide geben ja regelmäßig was
fasziniert sie denn eigentlich am gamen
falsch war ja für mich ist es einfach
die tatsache in eine völlig andere welt
einzutauchen in eine völlig andere rolle
einzunehmen
eigentlich ist für mich die faszination
beim spielen relativ ähnlich wie wenn
ich ein buch lese oder einen film
schauen hat eben noch
mit dem unterschied dass ich wirklich
selber der protagonistin wie ist das bei
ihnen
er hat bei mir hat sich das ist ziemlich
verändert ich habe angefangen
computerspiele zu spielen eigentlich als
auch als eine ersatzhandlung für andere
tätigkeiten ich habe lange zeit magic
gespielt ein kartenspiel ist zu sagen
dass die einsteiger droge ja in welcher
weise und magic muss man sich vorstellen
es sind einfach kreaturen und man
duelliert sich mit diesen kreaturen und
kämpft mit anderen und irgendwann gab es
ein spiel magic the gathering
battlegrounds und man hat diese
kreaturen gesehen wie sie entstanden
sind wie sie aussehen wenn sie sich
bewegt haben und das war für mich
wahnsinnig faszinierend was davor nur in
meinem agitation war und dann auch eben
tatsächlich am bildschirm zu sehen
und dann ging es weiter dass ich mit
freunden tatsächlich viel tiefer und
mario kart gespielt habe viele verreisen
fußballfieber ist unfassbar wie genau
und mario kart im grunde ein karton mit
verschiedenen anderen kleinen dingen die
man machen kann und das war sehr
spannend weil ich glaube dass das noch
eine andere art war unsere freundschaft
auszugeben weil man gesehen hat heute
gute oder schlechte verlierer sind das
war mir sehr wichtig tatsächlich nicht
mit leuten wie schlecht dieses
kompetitive ist es bei ihnen auch im
moment das wichtig ist oder gelben sie
wie sich weniger also spiele mehr
alleine oder wenn ich spiele dann mehr
so in der gruppe aber man muss gemeinsam
ein ziel lösen also ein problem lösen
genau was zeichnet denn ein gutes spiel
als ein gutes game kann man das sagen ja
ich glaube da gibt es ganz viele
verschiedenste punkte an denen man so
ein spiel bewerten kann
einigen leuten ist zum beispiel die
geschichte sehr wichtig anderen die
grafik mir persönlich kommt es vor allem
auf die game mechanikern und nicht das
packt dieses system das das spiel mehr
da liefert diese herausforderungen mit
denen sich mein gehirn auseinandersetzen
muss das packt mich am meisten
wahrscheinlich auch nicht das heißt sie
regeln für ihn aber das reden über ein
im spiel oder das system in dem man sich
bewegt als zum beispiel tetris ist
vielleicht ein beispiel dass man kennt
da muss man ja immer schön diese blöcke
zusammensetzen und dann gibt es spiele
die wirklich mein gehirn aufleuchten
lassen ich habe das gefühl ich werde
immer besser darin und das fühlt sich
einfach gut an dieses
immer besser werden und neue
herausforderungen bewältigen die
spielmechanik das ist glaube ich ein
gutes beispiel weil auch da würde ich
sagen ein spiel ist dann besonders gut
wenn die dinge ineinander greifen wenn
mal gucken was was zb ein buch kann ein
buch kann mir eine sehr sehr gute
geschichte erzählen
aber ich komme in dieser geschichte
natürlich nur als lesende personen vor
bei einem theaterspiel kommen natürlich
noch andere sachen hinzu da kann das
bühnenbild wahnsinnig teuer sein da kann
die musik ausufernd gut sein was ich da
aber nicht machen kann ist interagieren
und spiel also ein computerspiel für
mich deshalb besonders faszinierend und
dann ist es ein guter ein gutes
computerspiel wenn die dinge in der
spielmechanik ineinander greifen wenn
die atmosphäre zu der geschichte passt
und wenn ich trotzdem wieder aufs eis
in diesem spiel als interaktionen
vorkomme also das computerspiel ist eine
sehr umfassende tätigkeit die man die
man haben kann und wenn die welt nicht
da das gefühl habe ich komme da zu mir
ich bin da eine spielen de personen in
einem setting das für mich gemacht ist
dann würde ich sagen ist es ein gutes
computerspiel
es ist schon alles für aussenstehende
person ist es unglaublich interessant
das zu beobachten wir haben die bilder
gesehen davor das ist sieht ja aus wie
ein hollywood film wo man jetzt
mitspielen kann ist wahnsinn
die können sie sich diesen trend
erklären also wir haben die zahlen
gehört spielen weltweiten wie ein
drittel der menschen spielen games
beiden jungen sind es wirklich ganz ganz
viele was machst mach die fast nur die
faszination also oder diesen trend warum
warum ist es so weit gekommen
also ich glaube es lag jetzt auch
erstmal daran dass die computer erst mal
das leisten müssen was wir gerne sehen
wollen
gerade also viel mehr sagen jetzt hat
lange zeit immer besser aus als spiele
weil die realität abbilden konnten und
spielen haben spieler haben jetzt aber
sehr aufgeholt mit der ganzen grafik
verbesserung die sie hatten
und was hat dazu gekommen ist noch vor
ein paar jahren konnten viele leute halt
nicht wirklich spielen weil sie die das
equipment nicht hatten also hatten
keinen computer oder man kauft sich doch
nicht extra eine teure konsole um das
mal auszuprobieren und jetzt mit den
smartphones und der ganzen game
entwicklung auf den smartphones oder
auch mit browser spielen zum beispiel im
internet spielen ist das jetzt
zugänglicher geworden für eine große
masse von menschen und wer spielt dann
am meisten sind dass jugendliche sind
das meistens männliche person oder was
weiß man darüber
das ist dass er sich sehr
unterschiedlich je nach plattform und je
nach art der spiele also zum beispiel
auf dem handy sind was genau so viele
frauen wie männer und vor allem auch
ältere frauen was frauen also gerade so
30 40 jahre alte frauen spielen sehr
gerne handyspiele das sind für sie
erfahren dass er sagt ja noch drüber
aber doch auch mit 60 und 70 auch also
es gibt auch spiele und ganze game
studios sie sich nur noch an dieses ziel
google.com richten also das ist auf
jeden fall ein großer neuer markt das
heißt sie sind nicht die ausnahme aus
programmieren nicht ich habe es gesagt
sie sind game designerin sind sehr
erfolgreich
sie wurden 2017 von dem
wirtschaftsmagazin forbes zu den 30
wichtigsten personen unter 30 gezählt
ich reich technologie haben dieses game
nicht entwickelt das sehr erfolgreich
ist das schauen wir uns gleich noch
mehrere jobangebote haben sie
ausgeschlagen aus dem silicon valley
da muss man sagen um mit ihrem team dem
iphone studio hier zwölf person bleibe
ich in zürich games zu dieser heinz sie
haben sich also für die schweiz
entschieden gegen kalifornien steht denn
die schweiz da international
wir haben jetzt gerade eine studie
gemacht und wenn man das so vergleich
also die schweiz ist ein relativ kleines
spielfeld noch für für games aber wenn
man das vergleicht mit 2008 haben wir
jetzt 500 mehr studios also sein
riesiges wachstum auch an arbeitsplätzen
von dem er ist das super als ich damals
abgeschlossen habe als studentin war es
noch sehr schwierig eine anstellung zu
finden was auch einer der mit gründe war
wieso wir dann selber gegründet haben
aber mittlerweile wird es wirklich immer
besser ich also die schweiz kann langsam
mit spielen wie beurteilt der philosoph
diesen gesellschaftlichen trend zum game
das waren ja spielt ich glaube es kann
relativ einen guten aufschluss geben
wenn man auch mal auf andere kultur
produkte guckt zum beispiel auf die oper
wenn man schaut wie die oper am anfang
da stand dann wurde die tatsächlich als
seichte unterhaltung abgetan ganz lange
im gegensatz zum zum schauspiel im
gegensatz zur orchestralen vorführung
von musik und dann gab es so was ich
würde es trickl ab
den kulturellen praktiken manchmal haben
das ticket nach essig hat nach oben
durch und wird immer bekommt immer
größeres ansehen
und wenn wir da in die jüngere
vergangenheit gucken an comics das macht
durchgemacht comics am anfang irgendwie
verstehen als die jugend unterhaltung
als kleine heftchen mittlerweile gibt es
graphic novels es gibt sammlerstücke von
von comics die noch eingeschweißt sind
die zu horrenden preisen verkauft werden
also auch da hat man diesen nach oben
sicher effekt und da auch bei
computerspielen ich würde sagen dass das
ganz ähnlich wenn man guckt 1972 kampong
glaube ich raus und das erste
computerspiel dass man wirklich als
computerspiel sehen kann
ganz einfache mechanik im grunde ist es
die übertragung von tischtennis auf dem
bildschirm man hat zwei balken jeweils
ein spieler schiebt diese balken hin und
her und es gibt ein ball der
eigentlichen pixel ist weil es da war
konnte dann alsbald noch nicht ändern
und auch nicht darstellung genau und da
versucht man einfach dass der ball
jeweils auf der eigenen seite nicht
rausgeht dass da hat das angefangen 72
und es ist einfach an der zeit dass die
computerspieler auch nach oben in die
hochkultur durchsickern jetzt 2009/10
und dass der trend geht ja auch schon
weil ich glaube es ist ein ganz ganz
normale entwicklung persönlich ist
dieses spielen dieses geld auch so einen
gegenwert zum konkurrenzkampf im
heutigen kapitalistischen systems ist
dass die leute wieder sowie eine auszeit
suchen eine gegen werten protest gegen
das dass dieses zweck freies spiel sucht
das zweckfrei spiel ist auf jeden fall
wichtig und dann wer da auf den
kulturwissenschaftler johann herzinger
gucken zum beispiel der sich vielen
mitspielen
sie haben sehr darauf liegen den homo
ludens der sich da viel mit dem spiel
und auch mit einer definition des spiels
beschäftigt hat der sagt das spiel ist
natürlich auch dadurch definiert das ist
nicht die normale welt ist das ist
wahnsinnig spannend also ein spiel muss
abgeschlossen seien zum einen in einer
räumlichen sphäre zum anderen aber auch
in einer zeitlichen sphäre und die dinge
die ich da im spiel tue die
entscheidungen die ich treffe sollten
keine auswirkungen auf ein wirkliches
leben haben
und das haben wir natürlich im
computerspiel total also ich merke es
bei mir wenn wenn ich mal wieder von der
arbeit nach hause komme dann habe ich
keine lust zum beispiel mich noch weiter
mit schnitt techniken für video zum
beispiel zu beschäftigen das könnte ich
natürlich auch für den job nutzen
aber ich habe lust wirklich was komplett
anderes zu machen was tatsächlich auch
nicht nützlich ist für andere bereiche
und da ist das computerspiel glaube ich
prototypisch 20 auch interessant du hast
dich jetzt gerade noch den magic circle
beschrieben der magische kreis so nennt
sich das
diese spezielle abgetrennte dieses
umfeld nehmen sich die spieler bewegen
und ein anderes beispiel dass wir im
echten leben dafür sehen ist eigentlich
das fußballfeld es ist auch ein magic
circle ist war hier mehr als vier kreis
aber zum beispiel dass ich den ball ich
mit der hand anfassen darf das ist auch
einfach 1 regel die in diesem viereck
gilt und außerhalb nirgendwo und warum
sucht der mensch von klein auf dieses
spiel werden sie haben gesagt sie wollen
eintauchen andere identitäten ausleben
andere welten entdeckt ich habe eine
kleine tochter die dreieinhalb jahre
die steht am morgen auf und fängt an zu
spielen am abend geht sie wieder ins
bett das ist unglaublich starker trick
büro her kommt dass ich meine dass sie
mal nicht nur bei den menschen sondern
auch bei kleinen tieren bei katzenbabys
die spielen den ganzen tag mit spielen
bereiten wir uns vor
auf all die herausforderungen die auf
uns zukommen im alltag und im
erwachsenen dasein
deshalb ist das einfach inhärent in uns
drin dass wir uns mit neuen situationen
auseinandersetzen wollen damit wenn sie
dann mal wirklich ein treffen wir sie
auch bewältigen können ist eine schule
fürs leben eine schule fürs leben als er
spielen hat doch einen zweck auf jeden
fall ja das spannende am spiel ist nur
dass der zweck am anfang ich vorgegeben
wird also der tochter wird nicht gesagt
so und jetzt spielst du acht stunden
lang damit du ein mensch wirst sondern
die tochter sagt sich auch die tochter
sagt von sich aus ich habe lust jetzt zu
spielen und mache das solange bis ich
keine lust habe und also warum wir
spielen da kann man vielleicht auch noch
mal in die philosophiegeschichte gucken
da gibt es verschiedenste antworten
also wir können eigentlich anfangen bei
platon der sagt wir spielen in gewisser
weise weil wir spielzeuge der götter
sind
er sagt wir sind in gewisser weise von
den göttern gemacht als draht puppen und
vollführen ihren plan genau dann wenn
wir spielen wenn wir uns eingestehen
dass wir eben dieses spiel gucken sind
und platon sagt wir kommen die idee des
göttlichen dann am nächsten wenn wir
spielen weil die göttliche welt das ist
eine die es unendlich da sind die ideen
komplett idealfall kommen und wir als
menschen sind natürlich in gewisser
weise endlich wir haben unsere probleme
dann tut der rücken weh
der plan ist noch nicht aufgegangen und
im spiel vollführen wir aber diese idee
des unendlich und man kann es
philosophisch ausgedrückt sagen dass das
spiel in gewisser weise die transzendenz
das ideelle dass das göttliche in die
immanenz also in diese weltliche sphäre
holt also wenn wir spielen dann sind wir
praktisch halbgötter so dass wir die
platte sein und dann kann man einen
großen sprung machen
schiller hat den bekannten ausspruch
herr getätigt der mensch ist nur da ganz
mensch wo er spielt für ihre schilder
hersteller und wenn man das versucht so
ein bisschen aufzudröseln
dann versteht man das finde ich auch
sehr gut weil der ausspruch an sich sagt
ja nicht besonders für mensch ist nur da
ganz mensch wo er genau und schiller
begründet das so dass er sagt der mensch
ist eigentlich ein wesen zweier welten
auf der einen seite ist er ein vernunft
wesen das moralisch ist das das geistig
ist und das schöne will und das
sittengesetz nach kant befolgen will
also soll gut handeln und auf der
anderen seite ist natürlich auch in
gewisser weise einer in einer tierischen
natur verhaftet wir müssen schlafen wir
haben hunger
wir müssen andere triebe stellen und
wenn wir diese beiden dinge
zusammenbringen und spielen dann sind
wir eben weder auf der einen seite ein
sklave unserer moral wir müssen nicht
gut handeln und wir sind aber auch kein
sklave unseres unseres leiblichen da
sein sondern bringen diese dinge zu
haben und sind da wenn wir jeweils kein
sklave dieser beiden bereiche sind frei
darauf welche eigentlich aus der mensch
ist nur da ganz mensch wo er spielt weil
er in nur in diesem moment freiwillig
freie tatsächlich
das war schön und der johannes vincke
den sie schon erwähnt haben sagte ja
auch eigentlich muss man immer wieder
zum kind werden in den momenten wo man
spielt und ich fand es ganz interessant
wo sie gesagt haben wenn man entdeckt
neue welten mit regeln die man auch
nicht kennt und so ist ja auch ein kind
das heißt man fühlt sich so wieder wie
das kind muss neue welten kennen lernen
und entdecken wie die dinge
funktionieren und was die ziele sind
unsere halten wenn ich dann noch mal
kurz ein
das ist meine rolle als philosoph an
diesen ich würde auch sagen dass wir im
spiel tatsächlich ganz platt gesagt auch
zu subjekten werden weil die subjekt
zuschreibung also ich bin natürlich
dadurch dass ich nicht andere eine
andere person bin und das lernen wir
natürlich im spiel im grunde gibt uns
das spiel eine eine wiese um zu sagen
das bin ich nicht und das bin ich nicht
und deshalb bin ich selbst also ich kann
in einer relativ geschlossenen und
konsequenzen losen ja konsequenz losen
in einem bereich ausprobieren was ich
tun will was meine fähigkeiten sind was
auch meine schwächen sind also das spiel
macht uns tatsächlich zum menschen und
es ist ein mittel der selbsterkenntnis
schon wie sie hier treten also man man
lernt sich selbst besser kennen ja
gesagt so beschreiben viele
entscheidungen getroffen wo ich im
vorhinein nicht gewusst hätte wie ich
sie dann treffen würde bevor ich mit der
situation im spiel konfrontiert war
was haben sie beim spielen ja ich habe
gemerkt ich versuche schon eigentlich
immer die nette zu sein so gar nicht in
dieser spielewelt bin und ich kann jetzt
da reingehen und jeden aus raum halte
ich trotzdem
also irgendwie verhalte ich mich dann
habe ich gar nicht so das bedürfnis mich
jetzt also ich merke dann auch ich glaub
mir fehlt das gar nicht dass ich mich
jetzt so voll irgendwie die böse
richtung ausleben möchte und dass ich
daran dass ich dann einfach so allen
auch im spiel
nett bin interessant weil es gibt ja
schon gegeben trend auch dass man denkt
wenn man sich diese gewaltspiele dieses
shooter game st
da muss man irgendwas etwas archaisches
ausleben verbotene wünsche und ängste so
was neben dem im alltag nicht ausgelegt
werden können und sie sagen wenn sie
erfahren sich als ich hier angefangen
das will auch immer so jetzt rein und
dann mache ich das und das ist dann so
nicht
wo ist völlig überflüssig weil das sind
ja keine echten
aber warum ist das so also sagen sie
dann ich möchte in der spielwelt genau
der mensch sein der ich auch im
persönlichen bin oder ist es gar nicht
so rational
es passiert einfach ja ich mag ich es
einfach wenn es über überall friedlich
ist okay also ich mag schon wenn es
knallt doch also ich hab ich weiß nicht
ob es wirklich ein trieb ist den ich im
spiel ausleben muss aber ich weiß dass
es da keine konsequenzen hat ich habe
überhaupt überhaupt keinen drang in der
richtigen welt aggressiv zu sein
ich bin zum beispiel sehr froh dass wir
normalerweise probleme und konflikte
verbal lösen können also wenn eine neue
schlange an der supermarktkasse wird und
alle dahin stürmen und wer jetzt als
erstes dabei bin ich froh dass ich sagen
kann ok gehen sie doch gerne vor wenn
ihnen das so wichtig also ich habe
glaube ich im realen keinen großen drang
zu aggressionen aber im spiel weil ich
weiß dass es eben diese abgeschlossen
das faire und dieses komplett andere ist
kann ich da tatsächlich spielen und kann
jemand anders sein das ist wirklich also
ein für mich eine große motivation warum
wollen menschen das ja jemand anders
sein
ja ich glaube man hält sich alleine gar
nicht aus ich glaube dass das eine
andere große sache die die spieler so so
besonders macht der mensch ist nicht
dafür gemacht nur er selbst zu sein
wir merken das auch wenn wir in andere
kulturen gucken
jede kultur hat irgendeine form von
rausch erfahrung ob das alkohol ist ob
das pflanzen sind die man raucht ob das
in zungen sprechen ist die durch das du
was durch religiöse oder kultische riten
kommt wir brauchen diese
alltagserfahrung dieser anderseits
erfahrung und das spielen ist eine
möglichkeit zu gucken wer man noch sein
kann um dann zu sehen
okay das bin ich alles nicht so wie
früher die romane die man gelesen hat
und mit den figuren die man vielleicht
irgendwie ein bisschen schräg fand auch
der zeit gefunden hat doch das immer ein
teil von mir oder immer noch genau
werden die games die bildungs romane der
zukunft für mich ist das immer so sind
die games das neue in der zukunft mich
ist es nicht so dass für mich spielen
zum beispiel bücher oder filme ablösen
ich mag immer noch genauso gerne einen
guten roman lesen einen guten film
schauen wie ich spiele spiele
es ist einfach ein bisschen was anderes
aber vielleicht wird es ein ehrliches
bedürfnis erfüllen und unendlichen
status haben kulturamt entgegen der
gesellschaft ja ich glaube es geht in
eine ähnliche richtung weil ich auch
sagen würde wenn man heute versuchen
würde ein spiel zu machen das
funktioniert wie ein bildungsroman also
man hat die jugendjahre wo man merkt es
gibt irgendwie probleme man hat die
wanderjahre wo man dieses problem gelöst
und dann hat man eben jahre wo man
zurückkommt und sagt okay jetzt habe ich
das alles gelöst und jetzt bin ich hier
angekommen das passt ja gar nicht mal so
richtig zu unserer welt also biografien
sind so liquide so flüssig auch so
zerstückelt geworden dass spiele das
mittlerweile viel mehr abbilden können
weil sie diese entscheidungspartie haben
also wenn man sagen kann es gibt nicht
mehr ein startpunkt es gibt ein mittel
und es gibt einen endpunkt und wenn du
da sinnvoll hinkommst dann hast du das
spiel durchgespielt sondern was spieler
heute oft tun zum beispiel die treppe
kam human ein spiel wo man eine
möglichkeit hat zu sehen welche
entscheidungen getroffen hat muss das
vorstellen wie so ein flussdiagramm man
sieht du bist hier so abgebogen deshalb
ist diese möglichkeit nicht mehr offen
für dich sondern es geht jetzt hier
weiter
und das finde ich passt vielmehr zu
unserer heutigen zeit es gibt keine
übergeordnete instanz mehr die sagt es
gibt einen großen bogen sondern viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten und jede
möglichkeit hat irgendwie eine
konsequenz wir schauen uns dieses spiel
ganz kurz an
darum man spielt da einen roboter einen
androiden einen menschenähnlichen
roboter in diesem spiel detroit bekam
jungen mann muss diese entscheidung
treffen zum teil sehr schwierige
entscheidung ein moralisches dilemma
lösen
wir haben einen fall vorbereitet wird
die spielfigur sich entscheiden muss ob
sie einen anderen androiden einen
anderen menschen erwiesen roboter
erschießen soll oder nichts geschenkt
und das kurz an
wie die un mission
[Musik]
b
der haut
ja wir sehen hier die entscheidung zu
schießen oder nicht zu schießen mann ist
wirklich teil eines films hat man den
eindruck und kann bestimmen wird entlang
die geschichte geht ganz viele
philosophische fragen stellen sich
natürlich jetzt in diesem fall sind
social games so was wie moralische
übungen und kann man dadurch ein
besserer mensch werden
das liegt sehr an den gangs tatsächlich
weil ich da mit wittgenstein mit
bluetooth kann vielleicht sagen würde
dass diese spiele dann eine moralische
übung sein können wenn sich meine
entscheidung danach zeigen also wenn sie
mir nicht nur sagen hier ich bin ein
moralisches dilemma und guckst du hast
diese entscheidung oder jene und das ist
aber im grunde egal welche entscheidung
ich treffe das spiel geht ohnehin weiter
sondern wenn sich danach in die
spielmechanik in das wie ich weiter
entscheiden und wie ich weiter handeln
kann übersetzt wie ich mich entschieden
habe
also die die die geschichte muss sich in
der art wie spiele zeigen dann will ich
sagen ja auf jeden fall was man muss die
konsequenzen danach erleben können und
so weiter und je nachdem bereuen oder
irgendwie gut finden was man gemacht
wir schauen und sitzt noch ein zweites
beispiel an nämlich ihr eigenes spiel
ich habe es gesagt sehr erfolgreich fast
300.000 mal verkauft
knapp 15 millionen schweizer franken
eingespielt wir schauen uns mal ein
ausschnitt aus dem trailer und
vielleicht können sie müssen erklären
worum es da geht immer ich erkläre ein
bisschen darüber
das spiel war ursprünglich meine
abschlussarbeit an der zürcher
hochschule der künste und es ging mir
eigentlich warum ich möchte ein spiel
machen zum thema populationsgenetik wo
man wirklich auf
konfrontiert wird mit all diesen
bedrohungen die die natur ein
entgegenstellt also raubtiere oder zb
klimawandel auch man hat ein dickes fell
und plötzlich wir jetzt megawatt was
macht man denn und dann dann habe ich
ein paar coole leute gefunden die das
mit mir zusammen gemacht haben wir dann
unser studio gegründet und das war das
erste spiel das wir dann rausgebracht
haben genau und verkürzen haben wir auch
angekündigt dass wir für schulen
kostenlos rausgeben haben jetzt etwa 100
biologielehrer die es auch in der klasse
verwenden weil es ist wahrlich ein
unterhaltungsspiel und es ist so designt
man hat keine lernziele im spiel aber
die genetik ist relativ realistisch wir
haben da auch mit den hunden hunde und
katzen züchtern zusammengearbeitet die
dafür viel bei gegeben haben und deshalb
kann man da doch auch gut lernen wie
genäht genau abläuft
sie habe nach großes interesse an
biologie genau nicht nur das sondern
auch an comics ich habe sich dann
zusammen gespielt kann man sagen zu dem
namen richtig gießen game wie fängt man
so etwas sagen von null auf was macht
man dazu erst wenn ich jetzt so ein
spiel dieser einprogrammieren möchte ja
vielleicht interessant wenn wir das
studium beginnen machen wir zuerst
brettspiele lernen wir zuerst mal wie
überlege ich mir so ein spielmechanik
eigentlich einfach mal mit karton und
holz usw
und das habe ich tatsächlich dann hier
auch gemacht zuerst mal alles auf papier
aufgezeichnet mit kleinen figürchen und
man spielt dann als spieleentwickler ist
man eigentlich selber der computer und
jemand spielt damit allem und sagt ja
ich möchte dieses feld aufdecken treten
das um und dann sagt man was dann
passiert ist und so weiter
und das ließ sich jetzt bei diesem spiel
dann relativ direkt mit der gleich mit
dem gleichen regeln ins digitale
übersetzen dann muss man es dann
programmieren
dann muss man verschiedene 3d modelle
erstellen man muss jedes jedes ding das
man in diesem spiel sieht muss man auch
wirklich selber modellieren das kann man
sich vorstellen wie auch stone am
computer man fängt an mit einem block
und man muss ich okay jetzt gehts hier
rein und dann schneidet hier ab und so
weiter bis das dann aussieht wie so ein
tier und dann muss man das auch digital
eigentlich anmalen und so weiter und
alle diese teile kommen dann zusammen
setzt man zusammen da muss man noch
musik machen und so weiter bis man dann
dieses fertige projekt hat und das
dauert dann auch was drei jahre
das kostet dann auch also entsprechend
viel wenn man das mit einem team machen
möchte aber schon interessant dass sie
sagen sie fangen nach papier an weil da
muss man erstmal schauen dass die
spielmechanik die logik funktioniert
dass es ein land zieht und sonst
funktioniert auch nicht wenn das hübsch
angemalt ist genau also bei spielen wenn
einfach die grafik gut aussieht aber
wenn die entscheidung nicht interessant
ist schlichte vielleicht interessant ist
und auch einfach vor allem wenn sich
nicht gut anfühlt das zu spielen dann ja
dann hat den spielerinnen ja bildern und
reagieren darauf das feedback genau also
wir fangen dann sehr früh schon an wenn
das auch am anfang sind dass er nur so
block hin die in der gegend rumstehen
und da muss man schon mal trotzdem
gucken ok verstehen die leute wie ich
das jetzt bewege wenn ich ihnen sagen
wir das sind dann tiere usw
und da muss man dann viele viele
iterationen machen immer wieder neue
leute einladen
auch jetzt haben wir immer noch unsere
spieler die uns immer wieder neue auf
neue dinge hinweisen die sie nicht
verstanden haben usw
die wir dann immer noch auf zwei jahre
nachdem das spiel schon draußen ist
versuchen noch besser zu machen bei dem
spiel also bei einem spiel auf sehr
spannend fand war tatsächlich dass das
tutorial was ja bei vielen spielen immer
so ein bisschen so ein bisschen hakelig
daherkommen muss sich vorstellen hat ein
neues computerspiel und man weiß
natürlich überhaupt nicht wie man
figuren bewegt also man hat diesen
controller in der hand und wie genau ich
das jetzt aber machen soll ist mir erst
mal nicht klar deshalb gibt es am anfang
von spielen immer so lernen blöcke
könnte man es vielleicht eher lang und
das war nicht da sehr charmant weil das
die geschichte wenn es kurz erzählen
darf geht ja los dass man man wird als
als kleines tier gekidnappt praktisch
oder gefangen von einem vogel und auf
eine andere insel geworfen und ist da
ganz alleine und die erste anweisung ist
guck mal ob deine knochen noch heil sind
und beweg dich und es ist eben nicht
gesagt okay drückte den knopf nach vorne
damit du von diesem blog auf den
nächsten springen kannst und es ist
direkt als eine geschichte eingeflogen
also die art wie ich lerne ist da schon
spielerisch und da setzt sich natürlich
vor ort in den weiteren spielen
ich meine diese geschichten sind ja ganz
wichtig und die helfen hat damit man
eintauchen kann damit man in diesen flow
kommt der ganz entscheidend ist dass und
zustand vielleicht kann sich das kurz
beschreiben was das ist das anfühlt wenn
man so spielt versinkt und sich selbst
vergisst der flow zustand den haben wir
oft in spielen aber zum teil auch in
anderen situationen
das ist einfach der zustand wenn man
weder unterfordert noch überfordert ist
wir haben das scheinbar in unserem
alltag oft dass sie entweder und
überfordert sind und spiele probieren
ein genau immer schön in der mitte zu
behalten
mein bett anhalt immer besser in dem
spiel deshalb muss das spiel auch immer
schwieriger werden das sind so eine
kurve und wenn das spieler nicht gut mit
skaliert und nicht immer schwieriger mit
dann ist man zu langweilig und dann hört
man irgendwann auf deshalb probiert man
das immer schön gerade durchzuziehen
aber für mich ist das zum beispiel auch
beim beim malen bin ich oft in einem
flow zustand weil das genauso ich muss
mir immer noch alles sehr überlegen aber
ich bin in meiner komfortzone aber
gerade am rand meiner komfortzone zu
sein dass auf der flow zustand deswegen
auch diese levels diese unterschiede
dann ist man fünf gefangen und weiter es
ist sozusagen mein jetzige kompetenz ist
dadurch entweder über oder unterfordert
und dass es gibt der psychologischen
theorien die sagen dieser flow zustand
das ist glück ist ja oft bezeichnet das
ist von einem glücksforscher tatsächlich
ja so genannt wurde
die häufigsten mihai 1 ja ich weiß gar
nicht woher kommt aber ein
glücksforscher psychologe der genau der
genau gesagt hat nicht die
unterforderung nicht die überforderung
sondern genau dieser dieser sweet spot
diese kette was dazwischen ist und man
kann ja aber auch sagen im grunde ist es
auch zwischen ja in gewisser weise
zwischen langweile und angst oder
überforderung ist auch ich habe angst
vor einer überforderung und ich habe
auch keine lust auf langeweile und wenig
unterfordert bin dann weil ich an so
eine lange weile rein und ich glaube
auch also für mich haben diese floh
zustände im computerspiel auch immer
damit zu tun dass jeder meiner inputs
natürlich von einem anderen input des
spiels wiederum beantwortet wird
also wenn ich sage bei tetris das ganz
einfaches beispiel die blöcke fallen in
gewisser weise ich drehe sich so hin
dass die richtig fallen und sofort kommt
der nächste block der von oben
darunter fällt und ich komme gar nicht
raus und ich habe auch das gefühl gar
nicht richtig zu agieren sondern ich
gucke mir selber beim fluss meiner
handlungen zu und das können
computerspiele glaube ich einfach sehr
gut das wollen sie auch diesen punkt und
die zeit vergeht einfach mega schnell
das ist auch so deshalb geht die zeit so
schnell vorbei wenn man computerspiele
spielt oder wenn man etwas gerne macht
merkt man gar nicht was man macht und
warum geht da habe ich im flug und es
entsteht so ein heiliger ernst dann
obwohl es nur ein spiel ich habe fußball
spiel käme das natürlich ja das ist ganz
wichtigen ganz entscheidend aber es ist
eine künstliche welt das ist schon
interessant
und dann noch diese wiederholungen die
man machen kann also wenn man scheitert
kann man noch mal kann man noch mal
versuchen und im leben ist es ja nicht
so da kriegt man keine zweite chance
wobei ich sehr gerne spiele spiele die
einen nie eine zweite chance ausgeübt es
nennt sich zum beispiel per man darf
also permanenter tod das heißt wenn
jemand im spiel stirbt dann ist er weg
und wenn du willst dass er wieder da ist
muss das spiel wieder ganz von vorne
anfangen und was sind dann zum teil 50
stunden wieder investiert hast also ist
das dann wirklich hart sodass ich mag
das war meine entscheidungen dann
schwerer wiegen so nicht wenn ich das
jetzt mache dann könnte das passieren
und dann mache ich es trotzdem und dann
passiert ist nämlich oh nein
und wenn ich dann einfach den spielstand
wieder laden kann dann mache ich das ja
alles wieder ungeschehen
und dann kann ich alle möglichen
resultate ausgemacht dass er daneben
auch immer ich probiere dann okay was
passiert er mich das machen was ihr
bitte das macht was wisst ihr wie ich
das mache und dann nehme ich dann meine
lieblings sequenz und dann hatte das
alles irgendwie war das gar keine
richtige entscheidung mehr lebens
ähnlicher und das leben ist nicht
geringer
aber wenn ich fragen darf dann ist es
schon auch wichtig dass das gefühl haben
einen gewissen ernst auch in diesem
spiel zu haben tatsächlich für sie
fließt schon auf zusammen ich ganz ganz
erstaunlich dass immer noch das
gegenteil des spiels eigentlich der
ernsten schmeckt das gar nicht glauben
weil wenn man kinder in zukunft wenn sie
das spiel spielen
der boden ist lava man darf nicht auf
den boden treten man muss irgendwie von
couch zu couch hüpfen oder auf die
kissen die man hingelegt hat dann ist
das ding schon ziemlich ernst und ich
würde er dafür plädieren zu sagen das
gegenteil des spiels ist eigentlich der
zwang also wenn mir wenn mir jemand sagt
ich muss spielen oder ich muss eine
sache machen
dann wieder strebt das der idee des
spiels fiel fundamentaler ist der ernst
weil sonst auch immer ein teil des
spiels ist gerade wenn man sich jetzt
dieses boards wir haben's kurzen video
wir sehen diese leute die da spielen vor
dem ganzen stadion und alle gucken hinzu
dass auf jeden fall sehr ernst
da geht es darum gehe ich auch schon
viel geld ja genau ich meine wir müssen
jetzt noch ein bisschen über die
negativen dinge diskutieren die jahren
der gesellschaft auch da ist viele
eltern viele lehrpersonen machen sich
einfach sorgen weil ihre kinder zu viel
zeit verbringen oder irgendwie
gewaltvoll spiele spielen wissen dass
mit der gewalt mit david irgendwie
anscheinend einige menschen glauben das
würde uns abstumpfen oder würde und
selbst irgendwie unser gewaltpotenzial
steigern wie ist das dann mit den
studien was weiß man also mittlerweile
gibt es jedoch einige studien die das
auch widerlegen dass man keinen direkten
bezug gefunden hat man schiebt es immer
gerne auf die videospiele
aber ich habe das gefühl man schiebt das
auch immer gerne auf die neue kunstform
früher waren es dann die filme die das
verursacht haben heute sind die spiele
und ich schließe auch nicht aus als wenn
zum beispiel jemand sowieso schon einen
labilen zustand hat das alles mit dem
man in berührung kommt dass solche
handlungen zeigt vielleicht auch dazu
beitragen können aber ich denke wenn man
gut rational unterscheiden kann was
realität ist und was spiel ist denke ich
nicht dass es einen großen negativen
einfluss hat auch viele leute die bei
mir zusammen im studio arbeiten haben
früher shooter spiele gespielt sind die
liebsten leute auf der welt geworden
also ich sehe den direkten zusammenhang
schon nicht unbedingt wobei ich finde
auch man muss beim jugendschutz auch
wirklich aufpassen muss sich als eltern
wirklich gut überlegen kann ein
zwölfjähriger sohn jetzt diesen
unterschied sehen und man sollte sich
immer angucken ab wie alt die spiele
sind die man kennt da jetzt gerade
ausprobiert
das mit der gewalt und den videospielen
ist ja auch eine diskussion die immer
wiederkehrt und ja auch gerade gesagt
wurde
das gibt es bei ganz vielen kulturellen
erzeugnissen in der geschichte immer
wieder es gibt sogar vor den film los
die lese sucht im 18 jahrhundert dass
frauen in die zu viel lesen und dass sie
das irgendwie auch total verwirrt und so
also es gibt immer eine gewisse einem
gewissen vorbehalt gegenüber neuer
spiele aber ganz speziell auf die
computerspiele bezogen er liegt da
glaube ich so was ja wir fast wie eine
miese story also was ja der vorwurf ist
zu sagen nein meine nachbarn ist theorie
genau also was der vorwurf ist dass wenn
ich im computerspiele vermeintlich leute
erschießen
dass sich das dann auch in der echten
welt rührend zum einen ist das was die
statistik anbetrifft überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar weil es unfassbar
unfassbar viel mehr spieler und
spielerinnen gibt als es gewalttaten
gibt die gehen nämlich zurück und die
spieler werden immer mehr
und auf der anderen seite würde ich auch
sagen dass das töten einer virtuellen
personen in einem computerspiel auch von
der handlung etwas ganz anderes ist man
im grunde will ich ein bildausschnitt
aus und bestätigen die mit der maus das
etwas komplett anderes als zu sagen ich
habe ein gewehr in der hand ja aber es
gibt diese spiele werden ja schon immer
realistischer und es gibt auch
institutionen die waadt und etwa der
berufsverband deutscher psychologinnen
und psychologen warnt vor killerspielen
die mediengewalt kommission der
internationalen gesellschaft für
aggressions forschung es gibt immer noch
viele experten die die das anders sehen
das möchte ich einfach sagen sie selbst
sagen gewalt kann manchmal auch erziehen
oder je nachdem überhaupt nicht schlimm
sein und wir schauen uns ein beispiel an
das empfunden haben nämlich das spiel
god of war ii verhandelt aber kurz rein
entscheidend den trailer nase des
trinkers
pierre man sieht schon dass fließt viel
blut sind brachte jahr gebracht hätten
man kann sich vorstellen wie das
weitergeht
was ist was kann man da lernen gewalt
wenn man das spiel
das wichtige an computerspielen wenn sie
gewalt beinhalten ist dass sie die welt
kontext realisieren dass sie eben in der
spielwelt nicht sagen gewalt ist etwas
was du tun sollst damit du zu einem
richtigen ziel kommst sondern dass sie
auch ein heben und sagen gewalt ist
eigentlich ein problem und hier das
spiel das wir gerade gesehen haben man
spielt in einer jahr eine hollywood
fantasie praktisch den spartanern kratos
der mit chaos klingen und verschiedenen
ganz brachialen werkzeugen seine gegner
horden eliminiert oder nie damit man
kann es nicht anders sagen
der spannende dreh ist aber dass sondern
ende erfährt dass kratos einen band
eingegangen ist mit dem kriegsgott ares
und von aris gesagt hat hier alles ich
stehe da vor einem gegner den kann ich
so nicht besiegen hilf mir ich brauche
ich brauche dich und es sagt ja macht
das hier sind die klingen des chaos du
bist praktisch jetzt unbesiegbar und in
einem blutrausch mit diesen klingen
tötet kratos aber seine frau und seine
tochter
und das wird erst relativ spät am ende
des spiels dem spieler und der spielerin
gesagt und man merkt als spieler an sich
das womit sich die ganze zeit meine
spielzeit verbracht hat nämlich mit
gewalt ist der grund warum es der spiel
personen also kratos wahnsinnig schlecht
geht und auf einmal wird bald so etwas
von der man sich distanzieren will man
will gar nicht weiterspielen weil die
klingen mit dem man diese ganzen feindes
worden um gemäht hat sind eben auch die
die tochter und mutter irgend genau die
die mutter des tages aber das ist ja
nicht bei allen gewaltformen spielen so
denken wir an einen megatrend der
zurzeit herrscht nämlich fortnight viele
junge viele teenager spielen dieses
spiel vor neid
wir haben noch dazu bilder vorbereitet
da geht es tun dann man nicht auf einer
insel abgesetzt und kämpft dann gegen
andre und der der am schluss übrig
bleibt gewonnen so kurz zusammen gefasst
sie ist das da also ich meine
neunjährige spielen dieses spiel mehrere
stunden täglich hat suchtpotenzial
definitiv wie beurteilen sie das sind
diese sorgen berechtigt oder nicht
falsch war
die schwierigen fragen also ich sehe
immer auf jeden fall die gefahren die da
drin stecken ich glaube aber bei diesem
beispiel ist das problem nicht nur die
gewalt weil ich meine sie versuchen es
ja zumindest wenn man sie kein blut und
so weiter ich glaube es geht auch nicht
hauptsächlich darum dass man jetzt in
die dass man dieses spiel spielen möchte
um andere menschen zu töten sondern man
möchte dieses spiel spielen um der beste
zu sein
das ist ein so genanntes battle royale
spiel das heißt 100 leute kommen
zusammen auf eine insel und der letzte
der dann noch steht das ist der gewinner
das ist doch so ein nettes ich bin der
gewinner von all diesen leuten das ist
das gefühl dass gerade bei kindern sehr
stark starke emotionen auslöst und ich
denke hier haben wir auch noch das
problem dass man soziale aspekte hat die
da reinkommen wenn die anderen kinder in
der schule auch alle vorn spielen dann
möchte ich umso mehr diese eine letzte
person sein die da noch steht weil wir
das im echten leben dann auch
wertschätzung einbringt und deshalb
möchte ich da viel zu viel zeit
investieren um dann in dieser position
zu sein denn es gibt noch weitere
anreize die sie glaube ich problematisch
finden also sozusagen tricks die die
programmierer arbeiten um die genau
diese leute da zu behalten und diese
sucht zu nähren ja es hat einfach
verschiedene komponenten auch zum
beispiel das matching also wie das spiel
monetarisiert wird es gibt an
verschiedene arten wie man sein spiel
verkaufen kann wie zum beispiel machen
ein spiel wo man einmal zahlt und dann
hat man das spiel und deshalb gibt es
für uns auch keine anreize groß jetzt
die spieler möglichst lange dabei zu
behalten dass sie dann noch möglichst
viel zusätzliches kaufen so und so
genannte free to play spiele der ebenso
funktionieren dass das spiel gratis ist
das heißt es gibt schon mal gar keine
einstiegshürde für kinder usw
sie könnten einfach webseiten auf machen
ja und anfangen und das monetarisiert
sich dann so dass man im spiel selber
dann inhalte kaufen kann
und besonders wenn diese inhalte
dann auch noch vorteile bieten können
damit man dann diese eine person ist
oder zum beispiel bei vorteil kann man
sich dann outfits kaufen damit man cool
aussieht das ist natürlich dann auch
wieder so hey ich bin der der so cool
aussieht stoff wieder ein statussymbol
weil man das halt an alles kombiniert
dann hat man schon wahrscheinlich einen
ziemlichen suche wachsen
aber was haben die programmierer die
gesellschaft die politik für
verantwortung wie sehen sie das
da würde ich sie machen das ja auch mit
ihrem mit ihrem spiele entwickler team
man spiele zu generieren bei denen es
eben nicht per windows wie wir der
fachbegriff er also ich muss nicht
bezahlen
um besonders gut oder um besonders
erfolgreich zu sein
da würde ich tatsächlich zum einen
natürlich die die spielemacher die
spieledesigner community schon noch in
der pflicht sehen und aber auch dass die
spielen denn das in gewisser weise
regulieren wenn man hat natürlich auch
eine verantwortung zu sagen ich nehme
das ich nehme das spiel das im
übertragenden bild vielleicht eine
vollwertige mahlzeit ist also ist das
nicht nur popcorn und nicht nur erst
papier und nicht nur ich gehe da
kostenlos rein und so wollen wir dann
aber das update und das update und den
tanz und dieses kind sondern dass ich
auch sage ich habe überhaupt keine lust
auf fastfood wirklich ich will das spiel
das eine vollwertige mahlzeit mit langen
kohlehydraten ist das würde ich schon
sagen also da kann man aber kein
teenager hat zwölf jährige gleich 89
jährige das entscheiden
es spielen ja nicht nur teenager und
nicht nur neunjährige und ich glaube
wenn die wenn die große masse die sich
schon auch er von 18 bis 35
also das sind schon auch die
überwiegenden spieler wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe wenn die sagen
solche spiele da haben wir keine lust
drauf dann werden die natürlich auch
weniger gemacht weil die spieler
entwicklerinnen und spieleentwickler
weniger geld damit verdienen können und
also da sind glaube ich diese beiden
parteien in gewisser weise in der
pflicht ja ich glaube es ist einfach
immer sobald das geld gibt gibt es auch
jemanden der es nicht interessiert so
und deshalb habe ich schon auch dass
unsere regierung und so weiter bis zu
einem gewissen grad ein bisschen ein
auge darauf haben muss was erlaubt sein
sollte und was nicht genau also von
gesetzeswegen her
jetzt gibt es sogar gerade die große
debatte wegen blut boxen also dass man
ihn spielen inhalte kaufen kann so
überraschungseier kaufen kann weil man
nicht weiß was drin ist und zum beispiel
belgien hat das jetzt auch verboten das
muss jetzt klar aufgeschlüsselt werden
warum
und das vielleicht ist seine waffe
drehen die mich besten haut oder so hast
du halt nix prozent chance dass so eine
richtig gute waffe hast aber
wahrscheinlich auch nicht und dann kauft
uns halt ich sag mal wie glücksspiel
machen
genau deshalb wo es dann ist es auch in
der debatte weil geht's zu fest in die
richtung von glücksspielen
aber wenn wir gerade vorher über mich
geredet haben dass es ein kartenspiel
begehe ich in den laden
da kauf ich mir einen so ein päckchen
karten und dann mache ich das auf und
das in irgendwelche karten drin also das
funktioniert genau gleichen aber wenn
man es dann digital macht ist da nicht
mehr okay
und dann ist wirklich immer sehr
schwierig zu sehen wo ist jetzt diese
linie war es noch okay ist und was nicht
okay ist und was kann ausgenutzt werden
was kann nicht ausgenutzt werden
die gaming-community nervt sich ein
bisschen dass man immer nur über diese
negativen aspekte wie sucht und gewalt
und so und das wollen wir jetzt auch
hier nicht die ganze zeit machen sondern
noch mal gucken einige behaupten ja das
ist die neue kunstform das sind
kunstwerke und sie haben ein spiel
mitgebracht ein schweizer spiel das
heißt fans sales und wir schauen uns
damals ein paar bildern und tauchen da
einen diese welt
[Musik]
also es wert auf das ist ein sehr
ruhiges spiel vielleicht können sie
verstarb kurz erklären worum es geht
genau im spiel ist man eigentlich diese
kleine figur wie man jetzt was nicht
sieht die da hin und her rennt und man
ist eigentlich von uns auf eine reise
gehen und der gefährte der mann da hat
das ist ein altes fahrzeug das
ursprünglich vom großvater gebaut wurde
das ist das schwarzwald es ist dieses
fahrzeug und das ist schon recht alt und
das dunkel so ein bisschen vor sich hin
aber man ist auch davon abhängig und das
fahrzeug ist auch von der figur ab muss
die kleine figur ganz ganz kleine figur
und das geht eigentlich um diese
beziehung hier sieht man auch wie die
manchmal geht es einfach nicht mehr und
dann muss man das ding ziehen
es geht um diese sehr fragile beziehung
zwischen diesem fahrzeug und dieser
figur und dieser welt und was passiert
ist und wo man hingehen muss um
herauszufinden was jetzt essen wo die
anderen menschen in dieser welt sind
was würden sie sagen was macht das
kunstwerk also ich finde gerade
ästhetisch ist auf jeden fall ein
kunstwerk als wenn man jetzt ein bild
davon ausdrückt und in ein museum hängt
glaube ich würde niemand merken das ist
eigentlich über aber auch die geschichte
ist sehr kunstvoll erzählt und das ist
ein sehr atmosphärisches spiel für mich
auf jeden fall kunst für sie was macht
dein geld zum kunstwerk
ich würde da vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen weiter gehen weil wenn man ein
screenshot dieses spiels ausdrücken
würde und in eine galerie hängen würde
dann wäre das ja nicht viel mehr als ein
gemälde und ich glaube eben spiele
können noch mehr
tatsächlich würde ich sagen dass spiele
dann eine kunstform sind und ich muss
noch mal anders anfangen weil ich
eigentlich nicht sagen würde alle
computerspiele sind kunst und man würde
ja auch nicht sagen alle gedichte seien
kunst also ich habe mit 16 und auch
eigentlich noch letzte woche gedichte
geschrieben die definitiv keine kunst
doch keiner keiner würde bestreiten dass
gedichte geschrieben hat die oder
ingeborg bachmann höchste kunst wird
deshalb muss man glaube ich immer gucken
ist dieses besondere spiel das ich
gerade angucken kunst und der deutsche
philosoph daniel martin folge hat gesagt
spiele sind dann kunst wenn sie
sich als spiel zu erkennen geben und mir
sagen du bist ein spielender person und
ich werfe ich auf dich zurück er findet
er den sehr schönen begriff von sich
selbst durchspielen
also wenn wenn ein spiel mir sagt guck
mal du spielst mich gerade ich habe
bestimmte mechaniken die andere nicht
haben
im film zum beispiel wäre das ähnlich
wir haben vielleicht aus of cards
gesehen wohl wo die hauptfigur in die
kamera guckt und dann einfach man sich
mehr hat man merken da ist jemand der
sieht mich aus dem fernseher heraus an
und das ist schon mal sehr komisch da
sagt wieder aus der rolle fällt aus der
rolle und er sagt mir der film ich bin
ein film und wenn ein computerspiel das
tut praktisch aus der rolle als spiel
fallen oder gerade in seine rolle hinein
dann kann er noch einen schritt weiter
gehen weil wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel
wenn wir ein spiel werden hier in diesem
moment dann könnte ich in die kamera
gucken und bei ihnen zu hause den ton an
und dann kann ich wieder ein bisschen
lauter denen dann hören sie mich auf
einmal wieder und das ist natürlich
totaler wahnsinn wenn der controller zum
beispiel den ich zu hause in der hand
habe mir gesagt okay ich bin du spielst
gerade ein spiel dein körper ist auf
einmal was anderes weil du dieses spiel
spielst oder du merkst dass du ein
mensch bist dass du einen körper ich
meine sie haben ja auch ein beispiel
genannt in der vorbereitung die haben ja
so eine solche kontrolle dabei wo man
diese zwei joysticks sollte genau das
hat und da gibt es nun spielen
vielleicht müssen sie das flugzeug
kleiner dass das gibt ein spiel brothers
tale of two suns heißt das und das ist
sehr spannend weil man spielt zwei
brüder
naja und najeh und spielt jeweils einen
dieser beiden brüder mit einem joystick
also mit einem daumen praktisch und man
ist auf der reise man sucht das wasser
des lebens um den eigenen fahrzeug
praktisch zu heilen
und irgendwann ist der eine bruder
schwer verletzt und man kann ihn nicht
mehr spielen und das spannende ist man
hat die ganze zeit hat das ganze spiel
durchgespielt mit diesen beiden daumen
und auf einmal ist ein daumen einfach er
hat keine funktion mehr
und da sagte mir das spiel du hast mich
als spiel gerade in der hand und ich
zeige dir an deinem körper dass ich ein
spiel bin und da würde ich sagen da
fängt kunst an wenn das spiel dinge tut
dies nur als spiel tun kann und jetzt
nur als dieses spiel tun kann das für
mich der aufgabe ein spielzug ist sehr
interessant das heißt eine
selbstreflexion immer auf mich selbst
als spielender aber auch auf das spiel
aus bloßes spiel
jetzt möchte ich noch ein bisschen
weitergehen weil spiele erleben wir
jetzt ein trend hin aus der spielwelt
hinein in die echte arbeitswelt
lebenswelt und nennt das game i fiction
also viele das leben wir zu einem spiel
arbeitsprozesse versucht man zu
optimieren die leute zu motivieren indem
man spielerische elemente da hinein
macht man erzählt unsere schritte man
zählt punkte beim einkaufen und 2000 aus
spielerische elemente die zeit zu kommen
um uns leistungsfähiger zu machen uns zu
motivieren das schon gedanken der bei
holzinger drin steckt wie beurteilen sie
diesen trend
ja ich bin ja immer ein bisschen
vorsichtig weil wir haben vorher gehört
spiel und zwang ist das buch gegenteil
voneinander
also wenn es dann wirklich um
optimierungen geht und ich verstehe ok
ich muss jetzt das machen damit ja dann
weiß ich nicht wie motivierend dass das
dann tatsächlich ist aber ich glaube
gerade solche sachen wie cumulus punkte
usw
die als gaming fiction funktionieren
funktionieren schon ziemlich gut
ich beurteile also ich finde das
wirklich das ist ein großes problem ist
tatsächlich weil es der idee des spiels
komplett zuwiderläuft man ein spiel
fängt man freiwillig an man begibt sich
freiwillig in die in die hände gewisser
regeln und in die abhängigkeit von
anderen personen
und wenn ich mir vorstelle beim
arbeitgeber zu sein
der praktisch meinen bonus daran misst
ob ich genug mails am tag beantwortet
dann habe ich diesen diesem spiel also
praktisch diesem highscore nicht
zugestimmt ich muss einen bestimmten
rekord erreichen
und wenn ich das nicht schaffe dann dann
ist es in gewisser weise kein spiel mehr
sondern wie gesagt zwang und ich glaube
auch dass tatsächlich die gemmi fiction
immer noch kein richtig gutes wort ist
weil es bezeichnet es bezeichnet ja die
übernahme von spielmechaniken
in kontexte in die kein spiel sind und
eigentlich versuchen ihr leute die sagen
kelvin offizieren bestimmt der
arbeitsprozesse eigentlich versuchen sie
jetzt zu überwachen also eigentlich ist
es eine gewisse art von vielleicht nennt
man survey tainment also überwachung und
entertainment also die überwachung fühlt
sich nicht mehr wie überwachung an
sondern wird auf einmal ein
vermeintliches spiel zudem niemand
zugestimmt hat was eigentlich kein spiel
mehr das ähnlich wie bei den sozialen
netzwerken wo man daten sammelt bei
facebook usw aber auch wie aus
teilnehmenden punkte sammeln können
likes scherz
ja auf jeden also auf jeden fall und da
sind wir auch wieder beim glücksspiel
weil mir ist vor kurzem aufgefallen
also ich bin natürlich auch wie wir alle
wahrscheinlich bei instagram und twitter
und facebook und all diesen diensten
angemeldet und wenn man die seite lädt
dann zieht man ja diese seite so etwas
kennen und dann erscheint oben dieser
kringe und dann kommen die neuen post
das ist natürlich gar nicht so weit weg
von dem einarmigen banditen und man
sieht dass ich jetzt montag und guckt ob
dann die 37 streiks haben ja ich habe
jetzt endlich der post da ist der der
nicht befriedet in gewisser weise wegen
dem ich jetzt auf dieser plattform und
das finde ich ein super super krasses
problem dass das die glücksspielen
mechaniken und spielmechaniken
eingesetzt werden um leuten eben keinen
spaß zu geben was ein wichtiger teil des
spiels ist sondern um sie länger auf der
plattform zu halten
es gibt aber auch schon auch noch gute
beispiele für gaming sessions beispiel
ich versuche gerade japanisch zu lernen
und ich habe verschiedene programme
ausprobiert oder gibt's zum beispiel
einst das lässt mich so lange und so oft
lernen wie ich möchte und ich bin so
mächtig mut ich mich jetzt zu lernen
weil ich immer und überall kann und das
andere was sie da kann ich nur jeden tag
zum beispiel 100 wörter oder so
repetieren und wenn ich es aber nicht
mache dann ist das vieh verloren dass
ich sollte dann auch jeden tag diese 100
machen weil ich kann dann nicht am
nächsten tag 120 machen wir nicht nur 80
gemacht habe und dann bin ich wirklich
diese diese ich muss das jetzt machen
mechanik dass ich mache es dann auch
nicht mehr wenn manchmal klar es ist
eigentlich eine anstrengende der
mechanik die ich nicht toll finde weil
eigentlich möchte ich ja vielleicht auch
selber bestimmen können
aber es macht mich effizienz im plan
schlussendlich war das dann auch meine
entscheidung ist das funktioniert klar
dass mit ihnen zum schluss der sendung
noch ein bisschen über die zukunft reden
über die zunehmende verschmelzung von
spiel und nicht spiel von realität und
virtualität und es gibt ja auch neue
technologien etwa diese virtual reality
brillen oder augmented reality gibt also
angereicherte erweiterte realität man
kennt dieses spiel pokemon go wo man mit
dem handy was fehlt und plötzlich
tauchte eine fiktive figur in der
realität aber wenn man durch dieses
iphone ist das denn die zukunft diese
totale verschmelzung von virtuellen und
realen suchen wir das letztlich diese
version wie man das nach nimmt ja auch
da wenn man immer noch einmal auf die
grundpfeiler von spielen zur gibt ist es
wichtig dass spieler jedem andere
bereiche sind also ich glaube nicht dass
wir in das dieses studio zum beispiel in
100 jahren dann so sein wird dass wir
alle unsere brillen auf haben und wir
nicht mehr miteinander hier sind sondern
spielen müssen einfach ein abgetrennter
bereich seien und deshalb glaube ich
dass virtuelle realität natürlich einen
gewissen reiz hat weil man natürlich
doch noch mehr eingezogen wird in
gewisser weise aber dass das dass die
zukunft des spiels die komplette
versionen die komplette darin sein das
komplette darin sein ist das glaube ich
eigentlich nicht zumal man kann ja auch
ganz handfest darauf gucken wie lange
ich weiß nicht mehr wann es die erste
doppel trifft die erste virtuelle
rauskommt das ist so das ist so lange
her und es scheint sich nicht so richtig
durchzusetzen
und man merkt ja auch also wenn ich das
mal kurz auf ziel das ist ja doch auch
relativ schwer
und das ist ja doch auch irgendwie also
ich weiß nicht aber sie passt super zum
pullover
danke aber also ich vergessen mich jetzt
nicht und ich vergesse nicht unbedingt
dass ich diese brille auf meinem gesicht
habe und ich fühle mich nicht
reingezogen und aber es kann in zukunft
noch anders und handschuhe tragen und so
weiter es gibt ja auch dieses nintendo
wii das war schon ein versuch sozusagen
bewegungen mit reinzubringen das ganze
irgendwie ganz körper nicht mehr zu
machen also für mich scheint es
tatsächlich im moment auch immer noch an
der schweren und unbequem hat also ich
habe im moment mit bio games eine
weniger hohe immersion als mit nicht via
games weil ich meinen eigenen körper
mehr spüre aber ich habe auch das gefühl
dass ich das weiter entwickeln wird
und ich habe auch sehr viel denkt da
passiert noch sehr viel gerade mit
alternate reality
wir haben jetzt hier alle eine brille an
wenn ich jetzt hier bin jetzt könnte ich
hier auf dem tisch tetris spielen das
kommt auf jeden fall dass wir dann
digitale gläser haben wo mir sachen
sehen können dann muss ich bei pokemon
gar nicht mehr aufs handy schauen
sondern sitzt das ist die brille auch so
ein bildschirm ist und sachen in die
realität generieren kann und dann
vermischt sich das ganz genau das denke
ich schon
ich denke aber auch nicht dass zum
beispiel diese volle version dann andere
spieler ersetzt ich meine wir spielen
immer noch brettspiele
ich spiele sehr gerne brettspiele man
kann sagen pc spiele sind vielleicht e
mail sie war ich bin da mehr drin aber
für mich ersetzt das nicht dieses
spielen mit anderen leuten dass ich sie
ansehen und ich glaube auch da wenn man
dann noch mal in die nächste hier guckt
vielleicht diese angst dass leute
vollkommen reingezogen werden in
bestimmten medien die es schon sehr sehr
alten werten die leselust
wir haben aber auch den den tollen roman
zb von david foster wallace der auf was
zeigt der unendlicher spaß da gibt es ja
eine vhs kassette die eine so gute ein
so guter film drauf ist ja eine super
geschichte erzählt dass leute nichts
anderes machen und das ist natürlich
dass das was er da aufnimmt ist
eigentlich die angst dass der
farbfernseher die leute einfach
stundenlang und für den rest ihres
lebens im wohnzimmer wann wird weil wenn
da jetzt nicht mehr schwarz weiß sondern
auch farbe entfernt ist warum sollte ich
auch die perfekte illusion letztlich und
die frage ist ja schon philosophisch
interessant würden sie ein sehr gutes
spiel im leben vorziehen wenn man da ein
tagen könnte das würde sich alles für
real
warum nicht also wenn man sich praktisch
einfach anschließen würde und ich könnte
dann überall sein und alles haben und
praktisch sein werde ich möchte nein
würde ich nicht und zwar aus dem grund
dass ich will endlich eine entscheidung
dazu treffen müsste in diesem spiel zu
sein und wenn ich wusste wenn ich da
einmal drin wenn dann gibt es natürlich
keine realität und ich für mich
persönlich ist der große reiz am spiel
das ich wirklich entscheiden kann ein
spiel zu spielen wenn ich müsste alles
ist spiel ist eben auch nichts mehr
spielen
das sind dann einfach die neuen regeln
der neuen welt und dann ist das halt
dann die neue realität
und man will genau in andere realitäten
an
so viel habe ich gelernt habe hat vier
und herzlichen dank für dieses
reichhaltige gespräch in den kriegen
am kommenden sonntag geht barbara
bleisch den freitag ist für future
demonstration auf dem grund und fragt
wie weit ziviler ungehorsam gehen darf
und ob sich die welt mit
straßenprotesten tatsächlich verändern
lässt
zu gast ist der berliner philosoph robin
zertifikates jetzt gleich zeigt die
sternstunde kunst einen film zum moment
als der schweizer muss theatergruppe die
seit 47 jahren erfolgreich durch die
welt tourt bleiben sie also dran und
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]